la seconde journée de ce procès
historique a été consacrée aux enquêtes
de personnalité des accusés
sept prévenus se sont ainsi succédé pour
évoquer des éléments biographiques les
concernant donc pas question de
radicalisation de questions religieuses
cela sera abordée plus tard lors du
déroulé des faits ils ont juste parlé de
leur curriculum vitae leur parcours de
vie
ils sont accusés d'avoir importé un
soutien logistique notamment fournissant
des armes aux trois terroristes les
frères kwasi et à mehdi coulibaly ils
ont tous versé dans la petite ou la
grande délinquance mais pour leur
défense eh bien ces sommes ne sont pas
responsables de d'actes de terrorisme
c'était juste des trafiquants ce n'est
pas une opinion partagée par les avocats
des parties civiles ni par les victimes
et par les artistes ville c'est pourquoi
je vous propose d'écouter deux avocats
de parties civiles m cap swing struts et
m elie korchia à ce sujet la deuxième et
la troisième journée d'audience
il ne va pas révéler énormément de
choses à travers ces interrogatoires
depuis recul invités comme on les
appelle qui sont là pour retracer le
parcours de vie des des accusés je pense
que réellement les débats rentreront
dans le vif du sujet à partir de la
semaine prochaine
c'est intéressant on commence à écouter
ce que nous disent les accusés sur leurs
vies en tout cas sur les éléments
principaux de leur vie jusqu'au moment
des faits mais encore une fois ce n'est
pas là où nous découvrirons il nous
aurons des éléments de des éléments
particuliers sur le dossier annonce ans
à condition qu'ils soient condamnés bien
entendu puisqu'il bénéficie la
présomption d'innocence
s'ils sont condamnés bien sûr
contrairement à ce qui a été dit ce ne
sont pas des seconds couteaux sans eux
il n'y a pas d'attentats voilà et je
pense que des personnes qui sont
dans cette situation ne peuvent pas être
jugés comme des criminels de droit
commun
ce ne sont pas des crimes de droit
commun il faut ajouter que ce procès
hors norme se déroule dans des
conditions d'organisation très
particulière parce que outre la salle
d'audience il existe des salles de
retransmission pour que les centaines de
personnes qui vont venir assister au
procès puisse suivre donc
il y a des salles avec les victimes avec
les avocats des parties civiles avec le
public la presse et donc tout le monde
n'est pas réunies au sein de la même
salle d'audience il a des problèmes
techniques de retransmission du son
l'épidémie de corona virus vient encore
compliquer les choses les gens sont
masquées qu'il s'agisse des avocats
comme des accusés qu'ils ne peuvent
retirer le masque juste au moment où il
s'exprime
antoine comte l'avocat qui s'occupe des
victimes de charlie hebdo nous en parle
mon débat s'est par contre
l'organisation de ce procès que je
trouve quand même très particulière je
trouve que avoir un procès clac et comme
ça en plusieurs teintes extrêmement
difficile
ne pas permettre aux victimes d'être
avec leurs avocats avec les accusés avec
les magistrats
c'est aussi très difficile et c'est pas
conforme de mon point de vue à la
manière dont on doit mener un procès
dans ce pays demain suivront d'autres
audiences des prévenus qui n'ont pas été
entendus aujourd'hui avec une seule
ambition répondre à cette question
lancinante est ce que les prévenus
avaient conscience de mener une
entreprise terroriste lorsqu'ils ont
aidé les frères kwasi amedi coulibaly